[Music]
that's
your hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number two
03 I am Dr Brett Weinstein you if I'm
not mistaken are Dr Heather hying I am
last I checked yeah I mean what do any
of us really know but as far as we can
tell all these things are true at least
so far yeah and 203 not prime semi Prime
I mean everybody knows that's not prime
semi- prime 7 by
29 like I like a good semi- Prime yeah I
mean again who doesn't yeah Zach doesn't
apparently well it's not a
thing Zach our son and producer is here
to tell us that that is not a thing that
is not a thing well um so we know how
far we can trust him at this point yes
yeah come join us on Rumble if you're
watching elsewhere uh if you're just
listening continue listening wherever
you're listening and subscribe to our
channel here in Rumble join the watch
party on locals hang look to Heckle
locals is the place to uh say snide
things or to fight back against those
who do I feel like it's not heckling
because we don't see what's happening
during the watch party no it's the
perfect heckling for us not for them
right ideally for us the heckling is not
audible yeah okay well so today we're
going to talk we're going to return uh
to the top I of college presidents as we
uh spoke about some last week we are
going to talk about
um I have already forgotten um morbid
curiosity and Predator
inspection and uh we may talk about
Hanukkah a little bit as well uh but
until then um check out Darkhorse
store.org uh where you can get lots of
cool stuff we'll show some of those
things at the end of this episode we're
going to do a Q&A after this live stream
uh immediately following you can ask ask
questions at Darkhorse subm missions.com
all the questions you've been eager to
ask uh we're going to tell you more
things more places to to go at the end
of this podcast but for now we are going
to start with our three sponsors as
always at the top of the show three
products or in this case all products
rather than services that we actually
and truly vouch for here we
[Music]
go I take it on first because it's
awfully quiet our first sponsor this
week is Vivo Barefoot they were one of
our very first sponsors uh and they are
certainly one of our favorites Vivo
Barefoot makes shoes for feet everyone
should try them most shoes are made for
someone's idea of feet Vios however are
made by people with feet who know how to
use them and word is spreading people
have approached us because of the vios
that we are wearing saying they've heard
they're good and they really are these
shoes are every bit as good as people
say these shoes are Beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from surfaces
you're walking on is is amazing and they
cause no pain because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions simply fantastic our feet
are the product of millions of years of
evolution humans evolve to walk move and
run Barefoot modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to a Health crisis
people move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot Vio barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60% in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults for every
activity from hiking to training and
they make everyday wear there's also a
cert they are also a certified BC Corp
that is pioneering regenerative business
principles and their Footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials they aim
to protect the natural world so you can
run wild upon it go to Vivo barefoot
foot.com
darkhour and new customers get 20% off
all orders through December 31st
additionally new customers get a 100 day
free trial so you can see if you love
them as much as we do that's v i v o b a
r f o o
t.com Darkhorse for 20% off your first
order yeah we met um we met another
person this week actually a uh a
documentarian hello Garfield who was
wearing Vios and appreciates them very
much
and it happens a lot yeah it does happen
a lot
yeah all right our second sponsor this
week is seed a probiotic that really
works if you've tried probiotics before
and got nothing out of it try seed it's
designed differently from other
probiotics it's designed better it
actually works seed helps improve the
health of your gut microbiome which
means that it supports you becoming
healthier overall our resident gut
microbes directly impact the development
and function of the immune system even
before we're born microbes inform our
immune system teaching our body how to
distinguish between benign substances
and pathogenic antigens that is
substances that our body does not
recognize as its own you can support
your gut immune AIS in a variety of ways
including by prioritizing sleep new
research suggests that the gut
microbiome has its own circadian clock
and that changes to your normal rhythms
can disrupt your microbes and the
important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune axis healthy seed's
DS1 daily symbiotic also supports your
gut immune AIS seed is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strains
that be clinically or scientifically
studied for their benefits 16 of those
24 strains are specifically geared
towards digestive health and four of the
24 probiotic strains are known to
promote healthy skin your skin like your
gut has its own microbiome seed supports
both gut and skin Health seed is also
free from 14 major classes of allergens
including but not limited to sugar
animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn and
seed is basically double helded with its
capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain viability through
your digestive tract until it reaches
your colon where you want it and the
same design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary it's fairly
unusual uh for probiotics and among
other things it means that you can
travel with it seeds daily symbiotic
supports gut skin and heart health and
micronutrient synthesis people who use
SE seed often report improvements to
that digestive function within 24 to 48
hours so start a new healthy habit today
visit seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse
to redeem 25% off your first month of
seeds dsl1 daily symbiotic that's
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse at checkout such an elegant
design it really is obvious in
retrospect but a fine Improvement on
normal probiotics yeah and this point
about being able to travel with it is
actually huge if even if you don't feel
that you need probiotics on a daily uh
basis if you are traveling especially to
a number of places and uh going to be
moving around a lot where you're gut
Flora may not uh have time to get used
to the local stuff uh having probiotics
with you that you just take every day uh
can be um can be a gut changer yeah and
it's way better than trying to sneak a
quart of yogurt through TSA that just
you speak from experience I uh I ran a
thought experiment which again was going
to drive Alex marinos crazy hearing that
but uh yes I ran the thought experiment
and it wasn't worth it I see our final
sponsor this week is ancient it's Arma
Arma is colostrum colostrum is the first
food that every mammal eats produced in
the first two or three days of an
infant's life and is nutritionally
different from the milk that comes in
afterwards mammals have existed for 300
million years give or take a few tens of
millions and the first food every mammal
has eaten is colostrum colostrum serves
many vital functions including that of
protecting and strengthening the mucosal
barriers of infants before their own
barriers mature modern living breaks
down your mucosal and immune barriers
and Arma is the superfood that builds
back armor colostrum protects and
strengthens your body's barriers
creating a seal that guards against
inflammation and everyday toxins
pollutants and threats armor uses their
cold chain biop potent technology to
concentrate colostrum 400 plus living
nutrients into their most pure and
bioavailable form according to a review
published in the journal clinical
nutrition open science in 2022 bovine
colostrum has been used to treat cancer
AIDS polio heart disease and rheumatoid
arthritis it is a general
anti-inflammatory and its use in adults
is known to increase lean muscle mass
improve a letic performance and recovery
time support healthy digestion and
reduce allergy symptoms armor starts
with sustainably sourced colostrum from
grass-fed cows from their Co-op of dairy
farms in the US they Source only the
Surplus colostrum after calves are fully
fed unlike most colostrums which use
heat pasteurization that depletes
nutrient potency Arma uses their cold
chain biopot technology an Innovative
process that purifies and preserves the
Integrity of hundreds of bioactive
nutrients while removing cassan and fat
to guarantee the highest potency and
bioavailability of any any colostrum
available on the market the quality
control is far above industry standards
including being certified to be
glyphosate free benefits of armor is
colostrum also include clearing of
blemishes shinier thicker hair
stabilization of blood sugar levels and
acceleration of fat burning and
colostrum has been shown to
significantly improve Fitness endurance
and significantly decrease recovery time
after intense exercise armor has a
special offer for the Dark Horse
audience receive 15% off your first
order go to Tri
ara.com Darkhorse or Darkhorse to get
15% off your first order that's TR r
ym
a.com
Darkhorse I am very glad that none of
our sponsors this week are the
manufacturers of irons because I would
be in a very awkward situation I've just
looked at the Monitor and discovered how
wrinkled my shirt is so anyway if there
are any iron manufacturers out there who
wish to sponsor the podcast I actually
do know how to iron pretty well and I
would be willing to demonstrate the uh
the value of an excellent iron should
someone find their way to us yeah no I I
will say that um for reasons that I
somewhat understand and and somewhat
don't I detest ironing and I won't do it
and I basically choose my clothes based
on whether or not they will have to be
ironed and if they will I won't buy them
and you are then left to iron your own
stuff when when when they are when it
needs to be done and you occasionally
have even iron things for the boys sure
so this is actually one of the funny
ironies of uh being a man who travels to
give talks sometimes and formal is
clothing or at least clothing that
doesn't look super rumpled which is the
traveling inherently wrinkles everything
and so being able to unwrinkle your own
stuff is important why do people care
about wrinkles well presumably because
it implies something about your station
in life because if your clothes are
really un wrinkled it probably implies
that you have I don't know access to
servants or the money to pay people to
do do this sort of thing so there are
lots of men ironing their own stuff to
leave the impression that they have
servants that they don't have um based
on our historical uh using of this as a
proxy for uh your position in the
universe or a steam
cabinet I've triy to figure out which
part of that the Ste yes the steam
cabinet servants or a steam cabinet
servants a steam cabinet or historically
honestly a wife a wife right exactly
exactly and I do have one but she don't
iron no she don't iron so I do my own
ironing and I've gotten uh fairly good
at it yeah yeah except today ex today I
didn't I didn't get to it but uh yeah no
it's not that you failed at ironing you
failed to iron I failed to iron the non
irony of that is
stunning I know so if there are any iron
manufacturers out there consider getting
in touch with
him right consider yes do do reach out
uh but allow it to cool first indeed yes
yeah um Andy you prefer the plug-in type
right not the part not the types that
you have to put into the coals and then
pull out and clean off and yeah I'm not
big on those um yeah in fact you and I
have at times when traveling into the
field it's not that we wanted our
clothes ironed but there are many parts
of the world where you iron to dry you
iron to get the stuff dry and so if you
offload your your your uh clothes to
somebody to get them cleaned which is
often inexpensive enough to do it yeah
that's the way to do it in the world
yeah so you go into the forest looking
spectacular true for about two minutes
two minutes and then you're saturated in
your own sweat with then collects in
your boots but still well ironed Yes
except for the boots never had anyone
iron my boots it would be worth hiring
somebody to take pictures as you enter
the forest looking
dashing
indeed all right so um last week uh we
talked about what was then uh less than
a day old I think the this testimony uh
by the presidents uh from Harvard and
MIT and at the time the president aten
who has since resigned um before
Congress talking about whether or not uh
the student codes of conduct would
protect uh Speech calling for Jewish
genocide we talked about this at some
length uh and there is has continued to
be a story this week of course uh
president gay at Harvard uh has not been
uh not been asked to resign
not been encouraged to resign so far as
we know uh and whatever it is the board
I guess at Harvard has uh given her a
very light um suggestion that maybe um
maybe some of the borrowed parts of her
thesis shouldn't have been borrowed
things like that they have inquired as
to whether she might be willing to slap
herself on the wrist word has not come
back from I think she's not probably not
I don't think I don't see why she would
um but this prompted me to uh go back to
a piece that I in 2018 a year after uh
Evergreen had blown up I was approached
by the Journal academic questions which
is the Journal of the National
Association of Scholars uh in which I
was asked they said we've got an
upcoming issue on College presidents and
are wondering if you would be interested
in writing about college presidents and
specifically George Bridges and uh I I
recall laughing out loud at receiving
this email and then saying well yes of
course I would absolutely be interested
in writing about this so that piece was
published in 2019 and yesterday I
republished it with the um facilitation
of the journal academic questions on my
substack and I wanted to just read a few
paragraphs from it today um because uh
it is it is apropo you know we did
Evergreen was a canary and a coal mine
and there were things that happened
before that and it just doesn't seem
that the world is learning the lessons
No in fact um part of what we talked
about last time was that it may be
learning the wrong lessons very much so
uh the and and in fact as you pointed
out on Twitter um a number of folks
picked up on the same theme that we
talked about which
is the idea is not how can we regulate
speech so people don't say awful things
the idea is how can we um leave speech
free and not exert a double standard
exactly in which uh you know Jewish
genocide is a tolerable topic but
genocides of other people aren't which
is where we find ourselves exactly yes
so you know the excellent always
excellent Robbie George and also Heather
McDonald at least uh those two I think
others two have have um been using this
language of the double standard uh
Jonathan height as well okay um which of
course we did um last week in this very
Place uh so let me just I'm going to
read three paragraphs in the middle of
this piece on College presidents and you
can show my screen if you like Zach here
in biology there is a concept known as
historical constraint it provides one
answer to the question of why organisms
are riddled with so many imperfections
in brief historical constraint refers to
the fact that once a structure such as
an i is established selection cannot act
on it to make it better if the first
necessary steps in the process would
make it worse the vertebrate eye could
be improved for example by reversing the
orientation of the photo receptors as is
the case in octopus and squid but the
Improvement is left unmade by natural
selection because of the blindness that
would accompany the intermediate steps
an analogy can be made between
historical constraint and biology and
bureaucratic constraint in institutions
once systems are in place especially if
there are personel involved it is
difficult to get rid of them even as
they become outdated or redundant we see
calcification of once Nimble and Forward
Thinking systems into ever more rigid
and archaic ones this is in part what
underpinned Thomas Jefferson's
observation that even in a democracy
Rebellion need happen with some
regularity even the best systems will
become rigid over time and need an
overhaul and sometimes that overhaul
will not be doable in
increments bureaucratic constraint is
real and difficult to manage but what is
happening on many college campuses in
the last few decades is like an
infection quicker to do damage the move
to increase Administration effectively
guarantees a difficult to maneuver ship
even institutions such as Evergreen
where there was once pride in being lean
and Nimble in 1997 the anonymous authors
of the real faculty handbook at
Evergreen wrote that academic
Administration consists of quote a vice
president Provost with three staff and
five Academic Deans that's it the growth
of administration especially diversity
officers and offices who in the current
climate will be particularly difficult
to downsize or fire creates bureaucratic
constraint out of which some colleges
will not be able to maneuver the
infection if left untreated is likely to
be
fatal and this is what we are seeing I
mean Harvard is blowing itself up uh I
don't know what is going to happen as a
as a result of the of Penn's president
stepping down and just returning to the
faculty I guess the law faculty um and I
don't I haven't heard what's happening
MIT but you really the fact that we're
talking about these three is only
because they they were the three who
were hauled for congress this is a
problem absolutely everywhere and you
can actually see that that's the case
because what each of these three
individuals said was virtually identical
it was clearly coordinated and three
people left to defend the same um
disgusting speech would likely have come
up with different defenses if this had
not been centralized so there is some
Central Force deciding what is and isn't
tolerable and who will will not be uh
chased with pitchforks and torches and
um that centralizing force is an
indicator that this isn't about what
it's ostensibly about right the subject
that you're focused on is what you're
being told to focus on it's not the move
that is being made behind the scenes
about power inevitably that's right and
there you know there there are a number
of other points I make in this piece one
of them is that um we see in an ongoing
survey of sort of sporadic it's not
exactly um it's it's not exactly every
eight or 10 years but it's approximately
every eight or 10 years there's this
ongoing survey of college presidents
that's been done at the time of that
writing the most recent one was in
2017 and a few of the things that were
notable in that survey uh were one uh
there was a not there was an increase in
the number of searches for college
presidents and I believe this uh is true
at the level of the VPS including the
provos as well um that are done by
consulting firms as opposed to people
from the institution like academic staff
and faculty from the institutions that
are actually hiring the people um has
increased dramatically and uh of course
this will this will have a number of
effects uh one of them is a
homogenization right that if you are a
consulting firm who has become you know
expert in one of the few consulting
firms that is called when uh it is time
to hire a college President and you've
done this one this year and then you do
a second and a third and maybe 10 this
year and
20 the next your searches will come to
resemble one another you will come to be
seeking the same kind of people you will
come to be interested in the same kinds
of buzzwords and in keeping with that
what college presidents are saying in
2017 in a way that they didn't used to
um is that what uh what we really need
is a focus on diversity this is exactly
the moment uh that we actually have
increasing diversity in these offices
but instead the tone in the 2017 uh
report as opposed to the tone in
previous reports where there was sort of
increasing diversity and there was
encourage an encouraging tone about that
by 2017 we have simultaneously greater
diversity in these offices and this hand
ringing around why we haven't reached
Equity yet and what exactly would equity
mean with regard to you know the
presidency across Elite institutions
well I was going to say one can hardly
imagine but what it does mean is
whatever they want it to mean at the
time they're going to take whatever
Source population they want to compare
it to and they're going to only call it
done uh when they reach that goal and of
course they won't even call it done then
because they'll create some other goal
because the point in part is it will
never be done the work will never be
done we will never be done and that is
what keeps us employed so there's a
cascading as aspect of this yes right
these institutions are supposed to be
different from each other and in theory
they should be in a friendly competition
to advance the ball of human knowledge
and rise to the top of the hierarchy of
colleges and be more in demand as a
place to send your kids and all of that
but what this does is the same uh what
has been called by many who have looked
at the huge number of people inside of
Google and other platforms who do
nothing for a living apparently who mus
just proved this by firing a bunch of
them at Twitter and it humming along
better than it has been even before that
um that same
blight will accumulate inside these
consulting firms effectively they will
go through the motions of a search in
which they scrutinize the needs of the
particular college and all of this but
what they're really going to do is take
whatever it is that their search
algorithm has found and feed the
conclusions that you know they're not
going to take the top tier person and
feed them to the 20th tier University
but they'll have some way of figuring
out how to just take what it is they
already think they found and plug it in
and of course the number of people who
will be pretending to be busy figuring
out what the individual College needs
will be many so the blight will
accumulate inside the consultant
it will then flow into the
administration of these colleges which
will then hire faculty which are
pleasing to them and you'll get blight
on the faculty people who appear to be
busy studying this and that who actually
aren't contributing anything and don't
know how to sort truth from fiction and
lo and behold your student who arrives
there isn't going to end up leaving any
smarter than they were in fact they'll
be lucky if they leave as smart as they
walked through the door if it doesn't
actually infect their minds with
nonsense um so that Cascade of blight
through the entire system from
consultancy above the university through
the students flowing through the
university is inevitable with that
structure yes the other thing that's
inevitable is risk aversion yes a
consultancy that looks at a a college or
university that has a unique structure
and that maybe has unique people
applying for the job isn't going to say
hey you know what this person is a
gamble they don't look like the top
person for anywhere but in this case
it's worth it's worth this college
taking a shot because it has a long-term
problem that has to be solved for
example and this is the only person with
the vision who can do it what they're
going to do is they're going to resort
to whatever the college President
version of nobody ever got fired for
buying IBM right most of our listeners
are probably too young to remember that
but the idea was it wasn't that IBM made
the best stuff for your business in fact
it very well might not have but it was a
totally safe choice if you were in in
charge of figuring out what computer
system to get if you bought IBM it
wasn't going to cost you your job
because it was a mistake right so that
kind of
unimaginative infusion of bureaucratic
uh safety into these institutions then
explains I mean exactly as you're
pointing out why you would haul three
very different looking College
presidents in front of the Congress and
they would say virtually the identical
thing about this absurd turn of History
yeah that's that's right you just you
prompted me to just the paragraph before
what I read has these two sentences I
think in it Orthodoxy spreads through
the proliferation of In-House
bureaucrats uh but also through the
removal of discretion from The Faculty
staff and administrators who know
systems the best and Outsourcing the
Dirty Work to Anonymous others who at
best have generic interests in mind and
may also have perverse incentives
consultants for example are unlikely to
be persuaded by candidates who are
skeptical of the value of Consultants
right perfect right and in fact this may
be in your piece it's been quite some
time since I read it but um there was
something funny about George Bridges and
the consultancy that drove him to the
head of that search yeah it's not in
here it's not but as I recall it was the
second time that consultancy had uh had
driven him to the top I I don't know if
that's correct but I I remember there
being some Oddity like the same
consultantcy had resulted in him being
hired at Whitman um where uh those whove
been watching us for a long time we'll
remember a discussion in which we talked
about the fact that after Evergreen had
hired George Bridges some of us got
contacted by faculty at Witman to send
their condolences because he was the
just leaving president of Whitman yeah
and they like finally weree they knew
they'd been trying to pawn him off on
somebody and we were that lucky somebody
so um anyway it's a long forgotten
chapter I guess but not by some of us
well yep um if I had something a place I
wasn't thinking of going here but uh
what you're saying prompts me to deploy
a kind of piece of analytical toolkit
that comes from biology but has a high
relevance here and other important
topics we've been talking about let's
try it
out uh our listener should give me a uh
a bit of leash here I'm going to start
out somewhere it seems totally unrelated
there is a I just went to historical
constraint man so yeah yeah all right
hell yeah this is totally expect if
you're paying attention you should see
this one coming yeah give give us the
leash back yeah in the same condition we
gave it to you hopefully um the point is
about lions and other predators that
occasionally take
humans there is a tradition in virtually
any culture that lives among such
creatures that when a creature has
killed a person that it is the
obligation of the people people uh the
kin of the person who was killed to kill
the animal in question and there's often
an explanation for this something like
that animal has developed a taste for
human flesh and now must be killed for
the good of all the individual in
question who killed the human not we got
to go sacrifice a lion right and I'm
going to argue that this is in all
likelihood a metaphorically true belief
that it is not that the lion itself
has developed a taste for human flesh
based on its one delicious encounter but
that there is a very good evolutionary
reason for this belief to arise in every
population that has this as an important
danger and that the literal explanation
for this is something that nobody who
doesn't have an evolutionary
understanding could phrase so you would
expect just as The Germ theory of
disease shows up in the Old Testament uh
as you know God's uh desire not to have
you uh allow filth in Camp right that's
a belief that if you believe there's
somebody looking down it causes you to
behave differently as if you understand
the The Germ theory of disease this
belief that animals acquire a taste for
human flesh and therefore must
individually be hunted and killed even
at Great expense and risk to the people
doing the hunting and
killing um serves a function and the
function I would argue is to cause any
animal that has a pred disposition to
this behavior and I would point out
irrespective of whether that
predisposition is the change in some one
or a few genes that cause it to view
humans more likely as a
successful uh prey item um or it's a
cultural fact in on lions it could
easily be a cultural fact because Lions
uh have extensive contact with their
Elders they learn how to hunt from their
elders and so therefore a lion that
decided actually you know what the those
humans they resist less than you would
expect for an animal that size um and
there sure are a lot of them and they
stand up tall so you can see them from
far away while you're still in the grass
let's try hunting humans right some I'm
imagining a liant like at a whiteboard
explaining this to his yes that is your
developmental Distortion from having
seen so many Far Side cartoons as a
young person true to be back back when
the university used to teach science the
science departments were all plastered
in Far Side cartoons everybody's door
had them I included them in my
PowerPoints of course you did many of
the most important lessons were
teachable that way um but no more I'm
sure they're forbidden um yeah uh but in
any case the idea the hypothesis here is
that humans develop this belief because
if they do hunt down and kill at some
relatively frequent rate sometimes
they'll mistake which animal did it
right they might kill the wrong animal
and it might look like a perfectly
Preposterous kind of Retribution tion in
a place where retribution can't really
have any meaning um but if they more
often than not find the individual who
did The Killing and kill it then
whatever predisposition it is that would
cause an animal to explore hunting
humans will be stamped out because the
cost is so much higher than the value of
the meal that it got and what this also
means is that down the road the animal
will have a quote unquote irrational
fear of humans that because other
animals of the same from the same
population the entire lineage will
acquire a because the animal that's now
dead is not going to have an irrational
fear of humans no he will have a very
rational fear of humans has no fear
briefly as the spear is landing in its
skull yeah um but the others that are of
the same uh lineage the lineage will
acquire a predisposition to not
considering humans as prey if this is
done
effectively so we can debate whether or
not that resistance is seen I can say
you and I have both experienced swimming
with crocodiles that are perfectly well
capable of taking a human being in the
Panama Canal where except in the odd
circumstance that you get between a
crocodile and its babies or a nest that
it's protecting the animals treat you as
very dangerous even though on that
playing field you're no danger to them
and they're every danger to you um so
that's presuma the result of human
hunting having caused this fear of
people human hunting which when we were
there wasn't allowed in the Canal Zone
was forbidden um and there was no one to
do it right people were excluded from
the Canal Zone so anyway point is lions
and other potential human Predators
often trigger in people what seems like
an irrational desire to take Vengeance
on the individual who has killed a
person I take this to be an evolutionary
um adaptation for the reasons I've just
explained now here's my
point there are many political
traditions in which an embarrassing
episode even an embarrassing episode
that is arguably not the responsibility
of the person in charge results in that
person stepping down or being removed
from power right and this can seem um
paradoxical right to the extent that the
person just suffered terrible luck and
happened to govern over some
ungovernable moment then eliminate them
may be Preposterous it may even be bad
you may take a a good leader and remove
them because of circumstances beyond
their control y but a rational
application of the principle that if you
preside over a disaster especially one
that was preventable then you must be
removed from
power we don't apply this anymore now in
some places they do in Britain you know
there are votes of no confidence for
example that result in leader stepping
down and it seems uh Antiquated in some
ways we have an increasing exploration
of how to indure virtually any
catastrophe as a as a leader right Peter
dassk now has a large Grant to study
what happens when you infect Asian bats
with uh aggressive virulent human
pathogens okay how does Peter dasik
Peter dasic should have trouble getting
work at the local gas station why he's
in charge of gain of function research
on bats anywhere on Earth is almost
impossible to explain and this work is
due to be done in Colorado am I right
yes well of course Colorado and that's
it's very Central to certain things that
were something to get out which really
can't happen because magic um yeah no
it's a marvelous marvelously central
location but you know also Anthony
fouchy Anthony fouchy presided over not
only the uh offshoring of the work to
Wuhan that seems to have resulted in the
pandemic but also the catastrophic
Public Health response that was then
globalized um that didn't manage to
control the virus every error a person
could make the man-made M yet he stepped
down voluntarily as the you know he was
the most highly paid federal employee
now he has stepped down in good standing
his beloved right so another
Preposterous error and I would point out
something I don't think it was the
origin of this uh ability to withstand
disgrace but um do you remember Bill
Clinton yeah Bill Clinton I know this
sounds strange but was at one time
president and he suffered a terribly
embarrassing Scandal the result of his
own juvenile sexual behavior uh in the
Oval Office and at the time it seemed
that no president could possibly
withstand uh the disgrace of this I mean
just even the personal details of what
was discussed as a result of us
exploring what what he did and didn't do
was shocking but what Bill Clinton did I
think as a result of personal defects of
character was um
decide how to endure this by just simply
waiting for the thoughts that were so
shocking at first to um become uh
commonplace for them to be less shocking
I'm going to object to this as being on
your list I think one of these things is
not like the other so um I am no fan of
Bill Clinton I voted for him in '92 I
did not vote for him in 96 as you know
um but at the time even though I was
disappointed and then um deeply dismayed
by what we were learning about what his
administration uh was doing and what he
himself seemed to stand for uh
the the Monica Lewinsky blue dress
um
seemed unrelated irrelevant to his work
as president y now you know does what he
was doing in the Oval Office literally
um say something about his character
that is as it turns out
almost certainly true more globally yes
y uh but the idea that uh he should have
stepped down for uh personal
improprieties I did not believe then nor
do I believe now okay now I did believe
it then and I said it and my you thought
he should step down absolutely 100% even
though I thought it was uh a bum WAP for
exactly the reason you're pointing to um
so I was very angry at the Republicans
for
right turning this into a significant
matter but my point was actually bill
you don't have the right to put the
country through this and you absolutely
had an obligation not to create this
danger and the fact that you didn't
protect us from this the fact that you
engaged in this behavior that would come
to dominate our national Focus means
that you were not up to the job of being
president which he wasn't so you say the
same thing about um Kennedy about
JFK well it depends engaged in you know
far more of this sort of behavior yeah I
agree and I think that's a fair
challenge my sense is that the
likelihood that the political
environment in which this happened did
not put the country in the same danger
so you know that's not a difference in
the significance of the transgression
right it's it's you know arguably worse
in Kennedy's case but um but but the
danger to the country that bill put us
to I think was um substantial and easily
avoided for anybody who had any sort of
self-control so anyway that was my
position at the time so I guess at some
level it sounds like you were talking
about how it evidenced his character yes
uh and uh you know the the the proxy is
um look at what you're putting the
country through um but what you're
actually objecting to is is
um if you could not keep yourself in
control enough even in the highest
literally in the highest office in the
land uh then you have no business
working on all of our behalf exactly
exactly and even even if the answer you
know if Bill Clinton was a decent guy
which I don't think he is but if Bill
Clinton was a decent guy then I think
what he should have done is he should
have given a hell of a speech on the way
out and he should have said look this
didn't have to happen I made my mistakes
but this is politically orchestrated and
I'm stepping down not because this is uh
a political fact it's not it's
personally humiliating but um I'm
stepping down for the good of the
country because I'm a patriot and
because I do not want to put us through
what happens if I stick by my guns so I
guess um I guess you're like two game
game theoretic moves out and I am
thinking one game theoretic move out U
but I'm still not certain it's wrong so
um you know he he made an error that
even though the Republicans jumped on it
um he needs to be responsible for is
your argument and my position I think
still is um yes but rewarding those who
jump on errors then have an interest in
not only finding all the errors but also
potentially in fabricating errors and
trying to collapse people's careers on
the basis of errors that may or may not
even be true 100% agree with this and so
the point is this has to have backfired
on those who chose to exploit a sexual
defect to get rid of a president who was
powerful because he was popular yeah um
so anyway yes game theoretic now we're
talking about some Advanced chess here
because really the point is Bill Clinton
should have delivered a powerful blow on
the way out in order that this could not
become a strategy by the those who
employed it it had to cost those who
turned it into a scandal more than they
gained and it had to leave the country
in a better position and I think and he
also couldn't do that while remaining in
office he couldn't deliver a blow like
that he couldn't he could he could win a
personal Victory by remaining in office
at tremendous cost to the rest of us
which goes to the central failure here
of Bill Clinton which is he's not alone
in this but Bill Clinton I do not
believe was a patriot the idea that
anyone who's not a patriot should ever
Ascend to that office is frightening
Patriots should be you know table Stakes
but um but he wasn't one and his
character allowed us to see that and
then we went through some uh personal
drama over this at tremendous cost to
the country and the values he pretended
to hold and all of that but anyway back
to back to my point about lions and
other
Predators the you have to engage in a
policy that results in your system
evolving in the direction of um better
uh better navigation towards the goals
that you
hold so there's an evolutionary question
and the fact that we have lost track of
the idea that if you preside if we just
simply said look if you preside over a
an avoidable
catastrophe you got to go um even though
it might be that you were not in a
position to avoid the catastrophe the
catastrophe was avoidable but you didn't
have the the power but if we just simply
said look preside over an avoidable
catastrophe and you got to go then the
point is a that incentivizes people to
do everything in their power to avoid
the catastrophe and if they fail so be
it they tried um but it also means that
any tendency of the system to evolve
towards this corruption where people are
embarrassed but then they survive it um
will be removed it is potentially a
selective Force to uh changing the
system such that those who need do have
power to avoid
avoidable catastrophes do in fact have
that power right which brings me back to
George Bridges okay now George Bridges
was more than anyone else the cause of
the collapse of the Evergreen State
College that should have been enough to
toss him out on his ear the instant that
was obvious he was not the right guy to
try to clean it up and he couldn't clean
it up and he wouldn't clean it up he
didn't even try Okay the idea aidea that
they did not make an example of him by
you know they didn't have the ability to
punish him in any you know human way but
they could have removed his job his job
was not a right of his it was not a
personal attribute that he needed to be
you know given his day in court to deny
him it was a job that he was given
because the college needed a job done
and the fact that he did the inverse of
the job should have been reason enough
to get rid of him and you know had they
done that they might have been able to
hire an ex-president which long-term
viewers of the podcast will remember
they couldn't do they had three people
who got to the top of their search all
withdraw because none of them wanted the
job because it would mean managing an
insane faculty that uh you know couldn't
be governed just a little more detail on
that at the point that the presidential
search finally did happen because
Bridges said my work here is done um the
academic search was a no doubt done by a
consultancy
uh and you know with faculty sort of on
the committee but without much power um
they did the search they had uh a long
list they whittel it to a short list and
then as is what happens in F in academic
searches uh the three finalists
sometimes it's more but usually it's
three finalists who are on the short
list come to campus individually for two
or three days each of interviews and
presentations and um and and such and
these were the three shortlisted
finalists all of whom I believe memory
serves we were long since long gone by
then uh actually went to campus and only
after seeing campus and interacting with
the people on campus what yeah no thank
you right and you know any one of those
at that point who had said yeah I'll
take the job would have been an instant
College president and really could have
stayed for a year and then that's on
their CV and they could have leap
frogged to something else but all of
them said no way no not worth it even
though I forget how many
$100,000 went to the president uh per
year in that case certainly was paid
better than any of the other position
it was a it was it was not a bad job and
you got to live in a beautiful place and
they gave you a house and you know it
was it was a a sweet deal except for the
fact that you would have to deal with a
uh um a faculty full of people as mad as
a Hatter so trolls hiding under bridges
as I said trolls hiding under bridges as
you famously said then and and uh yeah
it's worth Reviving now yeah all right
so so okay so uh propo all of this a bit
uh and specifically the um the nastiness
at Evergreen in 2016 2017 which became
so famous on May 23rd of
2017 um Harvard is keeping its president
for now uh but also in Boston Harvard
being in Cambridge which is um adjacent
um the Boston Herald excuse me has
reported that Boston mayor Michelle woo
Who is herself a a Harvard grad um had
one of her staff mistakenly so it's a
staff error um not her error that this
went out into the world but it was
presumably her decision or she signed
off on the decision uh a holiday party
invite um was sent to all 13 members of
the city council instead of only the six
who are of color and specifically this
is a holiday party for quote electeds of
color Okay so the uh holiday party for
electeds of
color as reported by the Boston Harold
uh here's here's the article I just have
a few paragraphs to read from it first
uh this this is Michelle woo uh Harvard
grad Boston mayor uh a woo
Administration official on behalf of the
mayor mistakenly sent all Boston City
councilors an email Tuesday inviting
them to a holiday party that was me
exclusively for electeds of color
prompting an apology and mixed reactions
Denise dos Santos the mayor's director
of city council relations told the
body's honorable members that on behalf
of Mayor Michelle woo she was cordially
inviting each of them and a guest to the
electeds of Coler color holiday party on
Wednesday December 13th at 5:30 p.m. at
the Parkman house 33 Beacon Street I
include that because the Boston Herald
did and that's today so there you are um
this article is remarkable and here are
just four more par short paragraphs from
within it in an email to Dos Santos and
her colleagues counselor Tanya Fernandez
Anderson who describes herself as an
African immigrant and Muslim American
woman was more candid saying that there
is no need for apologies at all your
email should not offend anyone and there
is absolutely no confusion Fernandez
Anderson wrote just like there are
groups that meet based on shared
interest or cultural backgrounds it's
completely natural for elected officials
of color to gather for a holiday
celebration she added many groups
celebrate and come together in various
ways and it's not about excluding anyone
instead it's about creating spaces for
like-minded individuals to connect and
support each other further Fernandez
Anderson described the woo
administration's effort to organize a
holiday celebration specific to elected
officials of color as quote commendable
so there's a number of things there um
one of which is the fact that she has
identified electeds of color as being
like-minded individuals as if your
mutable characteristics inherently make
you of like mind and this of course does
relate to the fact that um people of
color which is a ridiculous
configuration a linguistic configuration
but okay we'll go with it for now uh
that people of color who don't agree
with this nonsense this Dei Insanity are
often called epithets epithets like
Uncle Tom uh because it would appear uh
that those who um buy into this Hook
Line and Sinker think that if you
disagree you are therefore sort of
handing in your of color card as well
that that somehow a belief can change
the immutable characteristic as opposed
to actually the immutable characteristic
is just another fact about me and I'm
allowed to think what I want but no not
here no not here I would just point out
an interesting connection to uh the
Meltdown at Evergreen right which is
we're talking about elected officials
that is decidedly different than holding
a cocktail party and inviting a group of
people who happens to uh have skin with
higher melanin content than folks from
Europe
yes but this
the degree to which a public College
inviting white people not to show up on
one day is offensive in a way that a
group that you have assembled maybe
because they are like-minded and happen
to have a skin color that is darker than
the average for the population or
whatever it
is those are opposite
things a public institution or people
who have been elected by a public that
is presumably not of color but is of
every huge including those who are
deemed not to be colorful right that
there's a responsibility in that right
just as when you ascend to the
presidency it is incumbent on you and
most of them are now just liars but um
it is incumbent on you to say actually
I'm not the president of the people who
elected me but I'm the president of all
of the folks you know of the nation
right the point is the the obligation
the moral obligation to be included Ive
in your thinking as an elective
representative and not to think in terms
of us against them especially where
color is the central fact right is clear
and it doesn't make this illegal but it
what it means is the fact that they do
not think twice about this right
obviously any white person who decided
to hold a holiday party for white people
who have been elected to high office or
whatever it is right would recognize the
insanity of that that idea but if if
woo wanted to just hang out with the six
counselors of color and not with the
seven counselors of non-color shall we
um she could do that but her
Administration official sent out an
official holiday invite right official
right so this is somebody receiving
public money to send emails that
obviously
are divisive right um about something
which if it is defensible at all it is
defensible as a private matter of a
private party that you are holding and
your choice of guest list is what it is
and presumably shouldn't be scrutinized
by the rest of us but to to make it a
matter of um an invite that has any
contact with anything public right is
obscene it's obscene and so in response
to the Boston Herald's tweet about this
article you can show my screen here uh
someone uh calling herself Queen of
Hearts SF said what language is this
electeds of color serious question to
which Mike questions writes electeds is
standard though bureaucratic often used
at the local level if many levels of
government are involved for example
councilman representative da of color
that means no crackers or Cracker
adjacency
yeah so I think we have people of color
and people of crackers are cracker J
cracker yeah no it's that's hit the nail
on the head
there um I don't know who my questions
is but Kudos sir that's that's brilliant
it's good stuff it is good stuff yes I I
feel that it as good stuff as somebody
who is undoubtedly cracker adjacent yeah
you're a spicy cracker or something
spicy yeah and everything
cracker oh my God this this this moment
and and the the people who are
defending um the right of public
institutions to exclude People based on
immutable characteristics are claiming
to be the Liberals yes wow so what do
you say to people like this it should be
something like you know I'll bet at some
point in your life you knew better than
this because I mean you know yeah as as
the power of the thing grows and
spreads um the loss of contact with that
which was common sense is just
unmistakable yeah I
agree all right all right that's that's
what I got on College presidents for the
move on from Cracker adjacency on to
other topics yes yes which may also
involve crackers and cracker adjacents
but who knows you know actually if you
are um incapable of eating wheat as I am
you will find that there are uh
many tortilla chips that function as a
standin for crackers and that actually
economically speaking they are
um they are quite a bargain our cracker
son would like to say something I don't
know if it's worth saying but we could
we could make shirts that said cracker
adjacent cracker adjacent I don't know
that we want to get into official
cracker adjacency um but I hear you
talking all right um ready to switch
gears okay so I wanted to talk about uh
a comparison between phenomena so I have
been doing what we all now do with which
is moving between real life and online
life and
obviously um there's a a question of the
ratio and too much online life is
obviously bad for you um but one of the
things that online life gives
you is the ability to see a slice of
many different lives integrating and I I
guess I'm over complic Li ating the fact
that I have
noticed in recent months and
years a decidedly High number of reports
of people's deaths that are
surprising now obviously there is
nothing new about this and I have used
the example of John Ritter the comedian
who died suddenly on the set of his
sitcom of an aortic section I've
forgotten how many years ago that was
but it was long before there was
anything like Co in the world certainly
long before there was anything vaccine
like and so I used mRNA vaccine like
yeah right exactly mRNA vaccine or mRNA
vaccine as the case may be
um I use that because I know that if
John Ritter had died in
2022 it would have been very difficult
for people to accept he's a Hollywood
guy he will have gotten uh Co vaccinated
y um you know atic dissection he was a
healthy guy um yada yada y people would
have concluded that it had been the
result of that technology and it
wouldn't have been because obviously he
died of it before that technology had
ever been
deployed so there's obviously lots of
deaths which if they happen in a
particular context people will see them
as the result of some new process but
because they happened before the
processes were there we can be certain
that we have we have a baseline of these
things and lots of people just simply
die but then there's a question of okay
you see a number of deaths of
people and the question is at what point
does the number in your circle imply
that some force is present that you
should be thinking about and this has
now become a problem because there are
many of us who have focused on the
hazard of the so-called covid vaccines
and the phenomenon apparently of sudden
deaths that seem to be Downstream uh of
these
shots but we don't want to have a
confirmation bias where we view every
death as this because we weren't doing a
good job of paying attention to the
baseline or because we're now doing a
better job of paying attention to people
who have died uh as a result of uh
whatever cause you know we are now
tracking these things in a way that we
didn't track them before we worried
about this and so anyway I wanted to
provide
some um toolkit for how to think about
these things and Zach you want to show
this just these are some things that
showed up we're up here in the San Juan
Islands um you know just show those
couple uh that I sent you this these
were just things that showed up uh on a
Facebook group here is a a local
herbalist who died uh Ryan
drum uh show the other one here's
somebody I think I had encountered a
couple of times but I didn't really know
him he was a local nature
photographer uh people were very sad
about his death the implication was that
it was unexpected now neither of these
are young men um they were clearly uh
older here's something that crossed my
feed this is uh David Ike's daughter
apparently at
48 now the question is what does one do
with all of this maybe we're seeing more
death because people are posting it more
maybe we see more death because the
circle that we are paying attention to
is larger I know that this is true in
many of our cases um just by virtue of
the way the internet works and the fact
that we accumulate a larger circle of
people that we follow we tend to follow
more people than we remove from our uh
followed list um so there are lots of
processes that could cause you to
encounter more deaths so you would have
the impression that people are uh dying
unexpectedly at a greater rate so um one
thing that I want to point out at the
top is that there is a what I consider
to be an absolutely maddening tendency
not to include the cause of death in
reports and I wanted to sort this
with some pieces of the puzzle that I
think uh many people will see as
unrelated until we draw the
connection there is a um a process in
nature where an animal that is being
attacked by a predator let's say and is
screeching uh presumably it is
screeching in part to try to scare the
predator or distract it so that the
Predator lets loose its grip grip and
the animal can escape that obviously
happened innumerable times where a
Predators has gotten uh gotten
distracted and that has occurred maybe
the idea is that uh if you're being
prayed on by a predator and you emit a
screeching noise that a larger Predator
might come along and if the smaller
Predator suddenly has to deal with a
larger Predator then they're going to um
let you go or the larger Predator might
succeed in catching the smaller predator
and the prey item might Escape or could
even be as a result of this last thing
which is something called Predator
inspection if you have a screeching
animal then sometimes what happens is
other animals of the same type show up
now this is especially clear if you're
working as I did uh with bats if you
have an animal if you put up a Mist net
a Mist net is a invisible net that you
would hang across a trail or other
flight way across a river um and as bats
are flying along bats are economizing on
um echolocation calls because
echolocation calls are expensive and so
they tend when they're flying in a
familiar place to emit many fewer calls
which is basically like turning down the
headlights on the car because you don't
really need them now this is obviously
something you can't do in a car but if
you were trying to save energy if your
headlights were battery operated and you
were trying to conserve energy you might
turn them down when you didn't really
need them and turning them up when there
was something to see it's like
navigating your house that you know well
in the dark uh and um not being aware
that someone has closed a door walking
into the door right did happen to me the
other day yes um but yeah and you can
navigate with a tiny number of photons
in general if the door doesn't happen to
interfere then you don't detect it but
anyway so bats flying across a familiar
path will have their echolocation calls
turn down to save energy that means you
can put up a net in that path and the
net not being perfectly invisible is inv
visible enough and a bat will fly in but
very often what you'll have is you'll
sit there for a half hour or an hour
with no traffic a bat will fly in
Screech because it feels like it's just
been caught by a predator and then
you'll suddenly get a bunch of bats and
that can be a problem if you're working
with bats cuz extracting them from the
net is something you have to be very
careful to do so you don't harm them and
you can go from having no bats for an
hour to having 20 bats all of a sudden
and the interpretation of this um is
that the screeching callus the animals
why would bats want to go watch some bat
being prayed
upon well because it's a tremendous
amount of information in that that bats
who hear that sound and follow it and
come and notice what's happening have
information on what is praying on them
and in what context is happening so for
example if there was a particular place
on the River where some animal was
leaping out of a Den right and it was
currently uh killing its prey well then
you might know that this is actually a
part of the river that you want to be
careful you want to turn your
echolocation calls up as you fly by this
location so basic Point Predator
inspection makes sense it's an
evolutionary adaptation designed uh or
as if designed to provide information
that is useful to animals that have not
been captured at staying not captured
mhm okay now I'm going to connect that
to something else which is something
familiar to people who think about
humans which is called morbid curiosity
now morbid curiosity is typically said
as if it's a characterological defect
that we all have to one degree or
another but there's some shame in it
right the fact that when somebody has
been killed or is in the process of
being killed we have trouble looking
away and we don't connect this as far as
I'm aware nobody connects this to
Predator
inspection right and so
what I think I'm seeing in terms of
reports of people's death is the idea
that you shouldn't be interested in why
they died the fact that you are
interested in why they died is on you
and I'm not going to feed your character
defect by telling you right and to the
extent that you find your curiosity
irresistible that's for you to sort out
with your shrink mhm I don't think so my
feeling is there's information in it and
to the extent that people are dying at a
normal rate and they are dying of things
that are not unusual then your ability
to track oh yes this person died of
whatever the cause was and yes it's a
little they were a little young for that
thing to have taken them but it's not
out of the realm of possibility here's a
person you know here's a child who died
of a stroke holy mackerel that shouldn't
be happening yeah right um so what I
want to say is a there's nothing wrong
and in fact the reason that you have
morbid curiosity is adaptive and and the
fact that you are being denied
information is gaslighting that is a
mechanism for preventing you from being
able to assess whether or not something
is or is not a pattern worth noting for
your own protection and for the
protection of your family we have the
right to know and I even see
journalistic Outlets reporting that
somebody has died and refusing to say
what of or what the circumstances in
which they were discovered suggest about
what of they're found floating face down
in a pool they can be presumed to have
drowned even before their autopsy maybe
their autopsy reveals that that's not
what happened maybe it was a drug
overdose and they fell in after they had
already overdosed or something but you
have a right to know and absent that
right to know then we all privately
Harbor our suspicions we do a terrible
job of collective sense making about
whether you know whether or not a death
look if somebody has been struggling
against a cancer for three or four years
yeah right then that's presumably not
Downstream of either covid or a covid
remedy it may be exacerbated by a
lockdown that prevented them from going
to Medical Care that they would
otherwise have gotten but nonetheless
you can categorize it differently and
you can say ah that one you know um that
one is not a contributor to the evidence
for this
pattern so but even some of the language
uh in obituaries that seems to be about
adding detail is actually obscuring
things like a long battle with cancer
I've seen things written into obituaries
a long battle with cancer and then later
on it'll say you know it was 18 months
like wow I 18 months I didn't think
meant long battle right so long could
could could mean all sorts of things uh
which lead you to different conclusions
right in fact I think uh your point is
well taken this is no place for
euphemisms this is a place for precision
and that Precision is not about
characterological defects and you know
obviously I mean maybe the reason that
we have this erroneous sense that morbid
curiosity is somehow um shameful is that
morbid curiosity is exploited in the
market in order to get us to watch
particular movies or or television shows
or to read particular books or whatever
right we can't look away and so to the
extent that these things play an
important role they cause your mind to
be very interested in the phenomena
around around such a death but in a
world where we are now dealing with a
huge array of
Hazards we need to be able to track
whether or not something is happening
that is causing a pattern of note that
implies a danger that we do not have a
good handle on
and if I can just borrow from another
story of late one that does not involve
a death but that I think makes the point
very
clearly um my dad is in his late
80s he still lives in Los Angeles where
you and I grew up and he had a uh an
incident some weeks back the incident as
it was reported to us is that he was
walking down the street I think maybe
from a doctor's appointment or
something and uh my parents are both in
quite good health for people their
age and he was walking down the street
and there was some sort of a homeless
encampment and there was a pair of shoes
one of which was next to somebody's tent
and the other of which was in the middle
of the sidewalk and my dad picked up the
used nudged it with his foot erant shoe
maybe he nudged it with his foot and
pushed it back over with its mate mhm he
then walked to the corner was apparently
waiting for the signal and was was
attacked from behind physically hit he
said he felt like he was hit with
something but he now thinks that he was
just the person physically attacked him
knocked him to the ground and this story
was reported to us uh with some
bemusement that this was
uh obviously odd that somebody should be
so Disturbed at the tidying up of their
shoe that had gotten into the path now
my feeling is you and I grew up in LA
an 80 a person in their
80s attacked on the
street for
nothing is decidedly not the world we
grew up in I'm not saying it never
happened but that would have been a
shocking event in
1978 and now it is apparently in keeping
enough with the world we now live in
that it is
um somehow a funny story well I mean to
be fair um your father did get medical
help and then um the police were called
and and the guy was uh taken into
custody actually right so this was not a
a nothing incident um that said the
great the larger context of the
conversation was in light of us talking
about how remarkable Prague had seemed
to us with to um the ability for us to
stand anywhere that we were in Prague
and watch people and see absolutely no
drama and what your parents were
responding to at first was saying well
but you know that's all the cities are
fine really right um and like oh
actually this thing did happen like in
the context of them assuring us that
actually American cities are fine too
and the West Coast cities you're fine
this story comes up which to to me is
what struck me as the as as the jarring
disconnect it's like how could that have
just happened and you have the sense
that the cities are just fine well and
um you know but you know may maybe that
was the only time that has happened yeah
it could be a one-off but it wasn't of
course right um and you
know the degree to which in the 70s New
York famously had a problem with
muggings now muggings did not typically
involve anybody getting hurt they
involved somebody being confronted with
a threat and giving up their money and
their watch or whatever that was
Dire this is well beyond that a person
in their 80s being attacked to the point
that they can't remain on their feet
that's serious under any circumstance
and the fact that it is in some way
um not surprising and I don't see how it
could be surprising you have a lot of
people for whom the match between the
opportunities in Civilization and their
capacity is such that they are on the
street surviving by whatever
means most of them presumably addicted
to substances that have unknown effects
on their perception their ability to
modulate their moods whatever it might
be so anyway my feeling is if you
teleported that story back to
1978 then the point is oh my God is that
a one-off event or does that imply
something about this city that isn't
factored into my calculation about
whether or not it's safe to live here
right the fact that it is not that now
has to do with a slowly boiling frog
issue which is that as the cities have
collapsed um extraordinary stories are
ever more common and people have gotten
used to them and that in
effect if it is you
know if it is turned into to well it's
impolite to talk about the attack on you
know your dad because uh you know about
the terrible circumstances that the
person who attacked him went through
that caused them to be this way right if
excuse making is what is deployed every
time you try to say hey uh you can't run
a store if people are allowed to walk
out without paying for goods um you
can't have a city in which people can
walk down the street and be attacked uh
by a monster um you know because they've
moved his shoe right we have a right to
M to monitor these patterns and
not bend over backwards to figure out
you know in what way could the attack of
on your father have been justified by
his behavior right you know maybe this
person was traumatized such that the
shoe remaining in the middle of the
street was necessary to you know keep
his PTSD under control and my father you
know whatever excuse making you're going
to go through the point is no actually
guess what cities have gotten really
dangerous that was the job of the people
who governed them to prevent it and the
fact that they haven't prevented it
means those people are incompetent those
people need to be removed from power and
somebody who doesn't make excuses for
these behaviors needs to be uh elected
into those positions those people are
incompetent and this
um but think about what the person who
aggressed against you or your father or
the city or whatever it is went through
and then give them a free pass and the
and then given them a free pass part is
usually not vocalized in those terms but
that is exactly what is being expected
and asked for and it's it's wrong and
and you know it's it's across the board
but that person thinks they're a woman
when they're not or um was offended by
the movement of the shoe out of the side
walk or is angered by your presence
because you look like a cracker right
like whatever it is or because you look
like a black person right like we we
actually not only um are not obligated
to accept these kinds of excuses we are
obligated to do the opposite we do not
accept the but that person who has
clearly done wrong has has some excuse
for it and
therefore we are behold to facilitate
them continuing to do wrong no the
opposite we we we do not facilitate the
doing of wrong in fact um this is a case
where um the left and the
right the conflict over personal
responsibility is completely maddening
and counterproductive yeah the fact is
we used to study questions about why you
know why uh there was so much violence
um in the 7s right which I think pales
in comparison to the violence of the
present but nonetheless we used to ask
that question and in fact there's some
very disturbing answers that have been
proposed and studied one being that the
lead that was added to gasoline
tetraethyl lead resulted in neurological
defects as a result of the fact that you
know lead is an element and it was being
it was pouring out of every tailpipe and
that resulted in people who lived where
that lead was concentrating um having
suffered un unknown harms that's one
possibility another possibility was the
change in Reproductive Rights resulted
in people who
um uh would have been born not being
born and that resulted in a decrease in
uh violence after it I don't know
whether later yeah but but the point is
these you we can ask the question what
explains this and the fact let's say it
was lad okay so you have a lot of people
who committed violence um because they
were damaged by lead does that mean that
anybody who can plausibly argue that
they were damaged by lead should have
been LED out of prison well I can tell
you what will happen if you do that you
will have a whole lot of violence and a
lot of people who didn't do anything to
deserve it will be victims of it so it
may not be a marvelous solution you may
not be able to cure people in fact you
can't cure people of Developmental
damage from something like lead but you
can say look here are the stakes if you
behave that way it's going to cost you
far more than you could profit by doing
it so don't right whether you feel it or
not whether you think it's a cool idea
or not don't personal responsibility
don't and it you know it goes back to
the issue of of the the Lions for
example that we were talking about
earlier the point is you need to set up
a structure where people or creatures
that explore a behavior that you do not
want explored come out behind so you
don't see more of it by whatever
mechanism whether they wake up every day
and Grumble about the fact that they're
not allowed to attack people or not they
may never get over it emotionally but
you need them not to participate in the
behavior that's the objective that's the
way we all get to be free and not walk
down the street wondering if somebody
who is defective for whatever reason is
going to LEAP out of wherever and attack
us right
that's that's exactly right um yeah I
don't I don't know what else to add it
just seems it seems so obvious it seems
so obvious and yet certainly the cities
of the West Coast and I think many of
the cities of the East Coast many of the
cities in fact across the country are
have are falling to this ideology and
this you know a holiday party for you
know electeds of color seems like it's
not part of the same problem but it is
exactly part of the same problem it is
exactly part of the same ideology um
that has decided that whatever you are
and whatever you feel is fine and it's
everyone else's responsibility to deal
with how they respond to the fact that
you attacked them or called them Dames
or spit on your like whatever it is um
and no actually you are first and
foremost responsible for your own
behavior you just are and there may be
reasons that you have a harder time
controlling your behavior than other
people do um that will be the case in
fact all of us have somewhat different
abilities to control our Behavior than
everyone else on the planet there is
there not you know three categories of
behavior control and all of us slot into
one of them we are all
individuals I'm
not right um but the idea that it's been
it's been offered up as a as a gift to
people to engage in reprehensible
behavior and our elected officials and
also the media and the people in higher
ed and many people and sea Suites across
corporate land have said oh okay well
then that's I guess that's the world we
live in now it's like no it isn't and we
get to define the world we live in and
let's just stop this yeah now I wanted
to go one further step which is let's
say you've got a pattern like it seems
to me that people are dying unexpectedly
at a higher rate than I am used to and
that that seems to match a
uh a change in our Behavior the public
health response to co for example okay
the problem is if I'm stuck with my
anecdotal encounter with the world and
this pattern and we could do the same
thing for the pattern of uh violence in
our cities then I have no way of
decisively answering the question the
only thing I can do is say does the
pattern continue to match the does the
pattern continue to anecdotally match
the uh predictions of the model I have
that there is something new and
dangerous uh at loose in the world right
um did I say at loose there's no at
looses there it's loose in the world
yeah all right if I had it to do over I
would just say loose in the world um
noted awesome I feel we're making
progress so what I wanted to do now is
show what you do if you actually want to
take that anecdotal pattern and the
hypothesis that result adult from it and
get rigorous and if you would show there
was a excellent talk at The covid Summit
in Romania I'm not going to show you the
talk it's worth the 25 minutes or so to
watch it but this is uh Dennis rainc
Court that's what it looked like in the
auditorium um and Dennis rainc court is
a physicist who has gone and analyzed
the all cause mortality data from around
the world he's looked at countries
different countries he's looked at very
different time scales um and so here
take a look this is the pattern of all
cause
mortality um by month
over 100 years
70 but okay yep um what you'll
see is a pattern of spikes and troughs
that your mind will correctly register
as highly regular now what that highly
regular pattern is is um an oscillation
of seasons and for reasons that rain
Court correctly points out are not fully
understood there is an increasing all
cause mortality that means we don't care
what you died of the question is we just
count deaths and we look at the pattern
people tend to die in the winter and
they tend to die much less in the summer
and the exact reason for that is not
perfectly
understood um now I would argue that
the
um the likely explanation for this is
somewhere in the neighborhood
of we all have some proximity to death
at every moment a force with which the
grave pulls at us
that force is quite strong in the first
year of
life it decreases radically over that
year if you survive to one year of age
that Force pulling you towards the grave
tends to be flat until you reach the age
of sexual maturity at which point it
begins to very gradually and then with
an accelerating pattern increase until
it's quite precipitous late in life and
then there is arguably a plateau large
largely due to what is likely a decrease
in your risk of cancer if you live
through the period in which cancer has
skyrocketed but in any case interesting
that the data if you plot it out reveal
this highly regular pattern and as
predicted this is Northern Hemisphere
this is France data you're looking at
here um very interesting and of course
necessary that it be this way if we look
at the southern hemisphere where the um
pattern of seasons is inverted then and
the pattern of spikes and troughs is
inverted as it would have to be
otherwise the explanation would be
falsified by it um so anyway that's what
the general pattern looks like um can
you show the next
graph I don't know what you mean that
okay so I maybe I didn't capture the
other graph you want to show his
bulleted list then oh yes so here is the
upshot from this
extremely uh carefully done research and
I want to call your
attention um
to especially number five uh number four
on this list 17 million vaccine deaths
worldwide to the present um uh plus or
minus half a million that is an
incredibly High number now of course the
number of inoculations given uh was
staggering you know obviously we're not
just talking about billions of people
who were inoculated but many of them
inoculated multiple times elsewhere in
this talk and again I encourage you to
go look at it he points out that the
risk goes up Rather precipitously with
the number of doses you've had uh
becoming quite high at um at the fourth
dose interesting um I wasn't there I
haven't seen the talk um but the fifth
point on this list fatal toxicity is
exponential with age with risk of death
doubling every 4 to 5 years of age um
that is not counter to but is the um the
opposite direction of what we have
talked about anecdotally what what it
seems to be the case not with regard to
fatality but Adverse Events wherein in
you know
2022 uh when we were talking about the
insanity of giving these vaccines to
young people um the point was that Co is
simultaneous a disease that does not
affect the young very much and these
vaccines seem to produce a greater
number of Adverse Events in the young
now we did not we never said that it
tends to kill the young more right um
but that the the myocarditis and
pericarditis specifically in young men
and um potentially um menstrual and
pregnancy issues in young women um you
know just because that's that's a young
woman situation um but is is more of an
issue um in youth uh whereas he's
finding fa FAL toxicity uh increasing
with age so I wanted to actually
navigate that a little bit yeah um and
this I'm drawing from the research that
I did uh back when I was doing the tiir
work and deeply embedded in the the
evidence surrounding inessence yeah now
sence which begins at the age of first
reproduction or average age of first
reproduction for your species and
continues to uh uh to accelerate through
life with additional
years um that
process
is the um it is the empirical
description of the vulnerability that I
was just describing the force that is
pulling you towards the grave now on
your 20th birthday the force that is
pulling you towards the grave is so weak
now if you're a male you may be inclined
to risky behaviors and we can argue
about what that pass pattern is but from
the point of view of the failure of your
biological systems at a critical level
that would cause you to Die the force is
extremely weak at 20 especially in the
prior world before all of the novel
influences you know you might now be a
20-year-old with a metabolic disease
that would make you much more vulnerable
but historically speaking you would have
had a very low um degree of decrepitude
at 20 right maybe only a few years and
accelerating at a very low rate and as
you get older the degree to which your
systems are compromised by this goes up
and up and up and so if you imagine as
Dr rort points out in his talk if you
imagine that the
MRNA vaccines function as a toxin and
I'm not sure that's exactly the right
description they are toxic but they are
more than that because of the way they
interact with the immune system but um
yeah they're not inert yeah they they
are they are a uh complex toxin the tox
keeps on giving indeed um but anyway the
point is if you imagine that every
person that you encounter is if if you
could look above their heads and there
was a number that indicated the degree
to which the grave was pulling on them
then you would say well if you were to
administer a toxin broadly across all of
them some of them that number at which
the grave is pulling towards them is so
high that it won't take very much right
now that's the same thing that we likely
see in the seasonal pattern right if
you're very very close to death then you
know the insults that come along with
winter right might be enough to do it if
you're very healthy and young then it's
not going to and so in any case I think
in part we are
um we are
hampered in our ability to understand
what's going on because death is such a
focus and the problem is death is a
binary
thing whereas damage is not right so to
the extent that something damaging has
been released on the public and that
that is measurable in the death of
people who were close enough in
proximity to the Grave that it pushed
them over the edge right and it will
very rarely get somebody who's perfectly
healthy and it will very frequently get
people who were headed that direction
anyway and um you know so we need we
need a better toolkit to think about
these things but my larger point is if
you anecdotally think that you're seeing
a pattern you're being denied
information on what that pattern is
you're not allowed to know what these
people died of therefore if you start
saying oh it's another died suddenly and
somebody says aha this person was sick
for 7 years it's not have died suddenly
as a result of these inoculations
because they were sick long before these
inoculations had ever been given to
anybody okay you win but um but if you
were interested in figuring out okay to
what degree were these things causing
that harm is the fact that I seem to be
seeing not only anomalies in the number
of people who seem to be dying but also
tragically the number of people who seem
to be reporting
um
serious disruption of of pregnancy yeah
right so you know again do they happen
under normal circumstances of course
probably some of that normally happening
during normal circumstances is actually
the result of other novel phenomena
toxins in the environment and who knows
you know metabolic diseases whatever the
novel influences are and then there
would be in an ancestral environment
that was free of all those novel
influences presumably a very tiny rate
of those things why in large measure
because the body is built to um not
invest in projects that are fatally
compromised and so there is a very high
rate of um spontaneous abortion which
presumably is a result of the fact that
the body is uh looking at a pregnancy
that's underway and deciding whether
it's a good enough bet to continue to
invest in it um so anyway there are
elegant systems in the body they're
disrupted by novelty the fact that the
public health campaign appears to have
created a
huge um quantity of excess death
something like 17 million people
globally and that's not even the cost of
the public health campaign that is the
uh parent vaccine induced deaths to date
so think about in light of the model
we've just put forward think about what
that actually implies if the if damage
was done by these inoculations to uh a
large fraction of the people who
received them and some small fraction of
those people were being pulled towards
the grave uh at a strong enough level
that they disappeared and they ended up
in our statistics then the question is
how many years of life are people
actually being robbed of what's the net
effect and
what is the total number of excess
deaths that will ultimately be
attributable to this um to this public
health campaign so all of those things
are interesting in addition to the
deaths that were the result of other
interventions that were uh that were
mandated you knowen ventilators and then
there's the question even more difficult
question this one I I don't exactly know
how you study it but there's the
question
of given the treatments that turn out to
work that were denied to people yeah in
order presumably to get them to accept
these um these
inoculations what would the number of
excess deaths have been how much lower
would the excess mortality rate be uh
had uh drugs like icin and hydroxy
chloroquin been administered more freely
absolutely which is affected by
something that raint says um in the
beginning of his talk which is um that
you actually do not see a spike of
excess deaths um that are related to
covid that they seem to be related to um
the measures that were mandated in the
aftermath of its announcement right and
this I
mean where did they get that vaccine to
us very very fast and uh had they been
able to put together a story
in which the vaccine arrived exactly
coincident with the virus then we would
not have uh the control group then we
could not say this is excess mortality
from covid which is to say oops 2020
basically nothing and this is excess
mortality uh after uh the MRNA
technology was deployed um if those two
things had shown up at the same moment
we couldn't compare and all of this
would be attributed to the disease yep
um are all right now
there's there's further road we can go
down but I think um this is maybe a good
place to to put this on pause for now
with the understanding that it what we
have done is we have taken the anecdotal
experience of a person who doesn't know
how to think about this we have talked
about um from that formulating a
hypothesis that then is in need of a
test and then the fact that that test
can actually come in the form of large
data sets that capture unambiguous
events like death and show us um that in
fact whether or not the specific deaths
that caused us to formulate that
hypothesis were caused by this exact
thing that they are completely
consistent with the idea that there is a
new force that it is a hazard that we
are justified in uh focusing our
attention on these deaths our morbid
curiosity in this case is a survival
Instinct MH that's it it's a survival
Instinct in and that to deny you the
information that allows that survival
Instinct to gather appropriate
information is a crime in and of
itself
excellent um I just want to revisit
which I think we have um on at least one
or two occasions uh since we've been
doing these live streams our Hanukkah
tradition tonight is the seventh night
of Hanukkah for
2023 and um as we have talked about
before and as we um put into it's not
the epilogue it's it is the epilog of
hunter gatherers guide the 21st century
um in our home one of our annual rituals
is to celebrate Hanukkah the Jewish
Festival of Lights that occurs just
before or around the northern winter
solstice we like the monora as is
traditional uh we sing sometimes badly
sometimes better than that and each
night review an additional principle
which is not traditional um I will say
that last night we did an vable job and
then you pointed out that we had like
reverted to some durge like singing and
uh you started us up again we did much
better yes much better recovered yeah I
don't know what happened exactly I I I
blame me I'm not sure exactly why but I
think it why that's interesting no you
didn't until I said that you know nice
nice try being an you just don't
do it very well no thank you I yeah um
so our families knew Hanukah rules and
we've I I have notes from 2012 um these
basically as written here so I don't
know how much before that we were doing
this but uh this is at least a more than
10e tradition on day one so basically
after on each night of Hanukkah we um go
over um the previous nights or days
rules and add the final one and there
being eight nights of Hanukkah um I'll
just read the eight here I will just say
um I don't know if this is Sac religious
or not we have done this to um honor
this tradition in a way that uh we have
obviously modernized in a personal sense
and you know this isn't the high
holidays right this is Hanukkah which is
a a holiday that's been um promoted I
think it's been UPR ranked because you
know because Jews needed a because of
its proximity to Christmas yeah and the
solstice which is probably why Christmas
is where it is and and all of that so
anyway um it's a holiday we uh feel
somewhat more at Liberty to play with
then then we would Gort for example but
so here it is day one all human
Enterprises should be both sustainable
and
reversible day two the Golden Rule do
unto others as you would have them do
unto
you day three only support systems that
tend to enage people who have
contributed positively to the
world day four don't game honorable
systems
day five one should have a healthy
skepticism of ancient wisdom and engage
novel problems consciously explicitly
and with robust
reasoning day six opportunity must not
be allowed to concentrate within
lineages day seven the precautionary
principle when the costs of an action
are unknown proceed with caution before
making
change day eight Society has the right
to require things of all people but it
has natural obligations to them in
return
that's mostly your work um it's a great
list and uh and each year we do it and
we ask our boys to uh remember each day
uh and in advance of us reading them and
they and they increasingly do yep they
have risen to the challenge and uh yeah
there's still there's one little place I
would rephrase something but um but
nonetheless I think it is uh useful to
think about what principles really rise
above all others in in the the
governance of populations uh or things
that aren't included in the governance
of populations that we'd be better off
if they
were very good all right um we're going
to be coming to you next week from a
currently undisclosed location but we
may or may not disclose it at the time
that we're coming to you from that I
think we're going to have to disclose
something well we're going to disclose
that we're not in our normal Studio next
week um but in 15 minutes or so we'll
come back to you right here with a Q&A
um so you can ask your questions at
Darkhorse admissions.com right now for
the Q&A that's be going to be coming to
you soon in the meantime consider
joining us at locals we've got lots of
benefits more all the time uh that's
where the watch party has been this hour
and will be next and uh we um release
the guest episodes of Darkhorse a day
early there we do a private monthly Q&A
we haven't done any May in a while but
uh we may do some coming up uh there's
oh we get access to our Discord server
there uh so seriously consider joining
us at locals and also subscribing to the
rumble channel uh we've got the store
Darkhorse store.org I don't know if you
have an ability to pull that up at this
point Zach uh probably not
um um but lots lots of great stuff at
the Dark Horse store um viser the
breakthroughs never stop blueberries
because oxidant happen uh Jake M micro
pizza if you're facing mask mandates and
you need an excuse not to put your mask
on just constantly eating micro pizza
and lots lots more um check out my
writing at Natural Selections again I
reposted that um on College president
piece there
yesterday we have um great sponsors this
week they were Vivo Barefoot seed and
armur we're going to have links to
everything we talked about in the show
notes and a reminder that we're
supported by you our audience we very
much appreciate your support once again
please join us on locals um join me at
Natural Selections we've still got stuff
going on at patreon but we're mostly
moving stuff over to local so that
you've got these great uh conversations
every month still at your patreon and
until we see you next time remember to
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside thanks for joining
us